welcome to pft ot on yahoo sports he's
peter king i'm mike florio going over
some of the big topics in the national
football league and there is no bigger
name right now in the nfl peter than
derrick henry first guy in league
history with three straight games of 180
or more rushing yards and so far games
of 185 and 192 in the post season is he
having the most dominant postseason
we've ever seen by an nfl running back
he is right now i mean mike
you know i wrote this in my column this
week
that the top five rushers of all time
played in a total of 46 nfl playoff
games
twice out of those 46 games
they had 140 rushing yards in a game one
of them did okay twice out of 46 games
so derek henry now has played four
playoff games
and he's done it three times
and
i think the thing about henry that is
really special
is that when you played jerome bettis
earl campbell
christian okoye you know the the really
good big backs in nf in recent nfl
history
you know
if you devoted enough energy and
personnel on defense to stop them you
could
when is the last time that bill
belichick has ever really wanted to stop
somebody and he failed miserably
i i don't i think derek henry might be
the first one on his list ever as a
coach of the new england patriots i mean
he wanted to stop marshall fogg he did
he wanted to stop marvin harris and he
did he wanted to make jared goff beat
him last year
in the super bowl and that's how they
decide design their defensive game plan
and it worked perfectly so
my point is that everybody knows
that derek henry is coming and still
he's rushing for 5.8 yards of carry in
this postseason and he is killing
really good defenses
yeah you know we see it in college from
time to time where the talent gap is so
great you can basically announce to the
defense what the play is and they still
can't do a damn thing about it and derek
henry peter that's a great observation
is approaching that level where you know
he's going to run you know it's coming
but there's nothing you can do about it
you know bill belichick said it's
impossible to prepare to face this guy
because you don't have anybody that can
in practice even begin to play like
derek henry you can never simulate it
you don't know what to do when it
happens and number one you're getting
blocked but number two you've got this
guy who is a freight train who is
sprinting not jogging or running but
sprinting past you
and uh yeah go ahead
we're gonna run the ball go ahead and
stop us and they're gonna do it over and
over again and until someone can stop
them peter they're gonna keep doing it
mike i don't know if you saw somebody
tweeted out a video of derek henry
entering you know approaching the titans
locker room after the game full gear
approaching the locker room and he gave
mike vrabel a bear hug now you look at
mike vrabel on the sidelines
big dude
you looked at derek henry and mike
vrabel in that hug derek henry
bigger dude he's a redwood
he's a redwood and he runs like a fast
tight end and in my opinion
i think
who would have ever thought mike think
about this
that in the final four of these playoffs
two weeks ago that in the final four of
these playoffs
that we would be talking about
on offensive player
on basically the 12th seed in the
playoffs because didn't we all think
that tennessee was number 12.
we did you know that we thought
minnesota was better than tennessee the
sixth seed in the nfc
and so here we are with the 12th seed in
essence
in the afc title game and the guy we
can't stop talking about is a player on
that 12th seed
and it's plenty to discuss as we
continue to get ready for conference
championship weekend where you've got
the best running back that we've seen in
the post season maybe ever and one of
the best young quarterbacks we've ever
seen in patrick mahomes somebody's
advancing to the super bowl and pick
against derek henry and the titans at
your own peril check out more pft ot
on yahoo sports videos throughout the
2019-2020 nfl postseason
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports